what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to a clip that somebody
sent me on instagram as you guys know
send me clips on instagram i love
reacting to things that you guys have
sent me before i start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell especially if you've
been watching for a minute if you've
seen more than five of my videos hit
that subscribe button
the only thing i might have done
differently i didn't marry
oh just before we start so this guy goes
around and asks people um
what do you wish you would have done
differently when you were younger i'm
going to restart it
the only thing i might have done
differently i didn't marry
and i could have married in retrospect
one or two of these people but i always
wanted um
i wanted to try something different i
wanted to live abroad i went with a
fellow
to africa for a while to nigeria
[Music]
and this is the conversation that a lot
of older the older generation really
isn't honest about a lot of people look
back at their life and wish they'd
started a family and wish that they had
married
and i really respect her for being
honest in this video because a lot of
people will die on the hill that they're
happy even when they're
clearly not
but i do
now
now i would like to have a companion
when i look at little children oh that's
really nice
and see this is what rollo tomasi talks
about um she as she said she had two or
three guys that wanted to marry her um
she lived with a guy in africa for a
little bit
and now she's old and
there probably isn't much
many dating options for her now
and she's alone
and it's lonely
but it never felt at the time
so looking back i might have tried to
combine it
yeah which is hard
it is but
i might have tried it
and that's what she's saying she's
saying
it didn't mean that she had to give up
her dreams to travel it could have just
meant finding a guy that also liked to
travel and who also liked to do those
things
um but a lot of times feminism has told
us that it's one or the other
instead of maybe something in between
you can like to travel and have a family
like it's not
there are ways to do things in
moderation
at worst
say you know it works it doesn't work
like with anything that's the word you
know so it doesn't work you try
something else
and that's also
a lot of women are afraid to try
marriage might end up in divorce your
odds are not good
but
does that mean we throw out the entire
institution altogether
at least when you look back in life and
know that you did everything you
possibly could that you tried your best
i mean at least you can live your life
without any regrets
but that is the tick tock that i am
reacting to today let me know in the
comments if you guys agree or disagree
with video this video don't forget to
subscribe and bring that notification
bell i'll talk to you guys next time